we cannot risk becoming a magnet for the
millions of people who are displaced and
seeking better economic prospects
many of our European partners are
struggling with the same issue Belgium
Ireland Germany and France are having to
take similar steps and the UK must adapt
to this changing context
I've said before that we have to suffuse
our entire system with deterrence and
this must include how we house illegal
migrants
so today the government is announcing
the first tranche of sites we will set
up to provide basic accommodation at
scale
the government will use military sites
being disposed of in Essex and
Lincolnshire and a separate site in East
Sussex
these will be scaled up over the coming
months and will collectively provide
accommodation to several thousand Asylum
Seekers through repost repurposed
Barrett blocks and Porter cabins
in addition my right or my friend the
prime minister is showing leadership on
this issue by bringing forward proposals
to provide accommodation at catterick
Garrison barracks in his constituency
and we're continuing to explore the
possibility of accommodating migrants in
vessels as they are in Scotland and in
the Netherlands
Madam Deputy speaker I want to be clear
these sites on their own will not end
the use of hotels overnight
local dispersal and other forms of
accommodation which we will bring
forward in due course they will relieve
pressure on our communities and they
will manage Asylum seekers in a more
appropriate and cost effective way
of course we recognize the concerns of
local residents
and we're acutely aware of the need to
minimize the impact of these sites on
communities
Healthcare will be available around the
clock Security will be provided on site
and our providers will work closely with
local police and other partners funding
will be provided to local authorities in
which these sites are located
Madam Deputy speaker these sites are
undoubtedly in the National interest we
have to deliver them if we're to stop
the use of hotels we have to deliver
them to save the British public from
spending eye-watering amounts
accommodating illegal migrants and we
have to deliver them to prevent a pull
factor
for economic migrants on the continent
taking hold
on Deputy speaker in action is not an
option the British people rightly want
us to tackle illegal migration
as I've set out today we are doing
exactly that and I commend this
statement to the house